[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah hey we might be drunk folks here we
are we're here we're hold on
wow that's unpleasant that was
yeah that was too much sorry that was
like the three godfathers but only the
third godfather
yeah yeah i had chipotle earlier did you
yeah i love chipotle do you go sour
cream or cheese no you're still fart
like that no dairy respect thank you
that stuff does nothing i know you're
trying to sober up right now this [ __ ]
does nothing you don't think
have you tried it i have i've been
drinking 5000 of these it's given me so
much false hope i always think this
stuff's gonna cure my hangover no
everything's gonna prevent the hangover
what does it do it just [ __ ] fills me
with sugar and i'm still hungover yeah
the sugar is a bummer i didn't know
there was a lot of sugar is that right
uh not a ton but enough that i'm like eh
yeah all right yeah look at that let's
see i'll stick with coffee and keep
shriveling up yeah diuretic by the way
diarrhea i'll tell you that much i'll
tell you that gives me a ton of diarrhea
i spray the bowl like a [ __ ] salad
i'll tell you it's a pollock movie in
there oh i'll tell you
it's all right sally's back
we missed you buddy
good to be back good to have you the
only guy
who was rocking hawaiian shirts when
they weren't cool then they were
and now they're back to nut
good to have i'm gonna write it out you
look good man hey feeling good we think
you're cooler than ron jeremy we don't
care
[ __ ] those comments hey and you never
raped so we'll give you that too yes he
can't get it up
oh this is a classic photo those are the
uh it was like a play on of mice and men
these two is that what it was yeah real
gangster types yeah yeah but i think the
the little guy and the big guy
okay but uh yeah they were like uh how
you doing see yeah mugsy yeah
classic the tiny gangster yeah funny how
gangsters changed you know throughout
the years it was italian
and then it went to black and who knows
where it is now
jewish maybe madoff well it was jewish
before italian was it yeah sure man
what
and jewish boxers by the way hey we were
tough yeah oppression is a hell of a
motivation motivational tool sure yeah
you don't see a lot of jewish boxers
these days though no they're too bad too
busy killing it financially yeah they
don't need to be back bad neck i'm just
talking enough about myself
i know can you imagine the jewish boxing
league at at the end of the day like my
vae where's the ice pack yeah he's out
for uh five to seven weeks with bad
allergies
yeah quick we need some claritin d
he's fading in this corner
shlomo's going up against derry
he's ruined ding ding one
two
three four oh [ __ ] my diarrhea
well he lost because it was a drafty
boxing ring
more jewish stereotypes all right
now all right uh
yeah man how you doing oh you started
like you had like a thing no no here we
go folks what are you
you're trying to kill this hang on i'm
trying well i'm trying we had a we had a
long episode with uh
another guest we really drank it up so i
got the the granules at the bottom here
and i can't get them all in and i want
to make sure i get all of it in this one
gulp yeah dude so you got to mix it up
with these float all over your [ __ ]
chest yeah they stick to the bottom here
we go swigging it keeps wigging it and
here's the money shot folks can yes he
did well good job
should i have that stuff too yeah
there's one left i know but there's no
water they can give us water in here
they got interns here yeah and some
interns
so what what's going on with elon musk
and twitter what do you think i gotta
say something first i found something
please might interest you you guys
friends with dave smith yeah this has
been making i mean i've seen him in
forever but i mean i'll always love dave
tweet from 2017 is making the rounds
again oh really yeah here it is he was a
smart guy
i love twitter he's not dead oh yeah
he's dead
you should buy it then is this a
different dave smith same comedian dave
smith okay because he's his avatar is a
bald guy and he's a good looking zoom in
that's not the dave smith we know he
said comedian dave smith no it's
probably him it's probably a joke
ah thank you thank you sir interns
[Laughter]
wait i'm sure it's him okay
uh okay it's a common name what do we
know you should that's true you should
buy it then how much is it whoa
2017. dave smith's a smart [ __ ]
he knows his stuff
is that him dave smith that's not him
what does the bio say host and producer
it's not that's not the name it's not
the same day
i like where your head's at sorry bro
yeah damn like where your head's at a
lot later
not even drunk yet what if isis ever
said that i like where your head's in
after the old beheading what are we
doing here
liquid iv concord grape oh
my concord just give us grape what are
we doing here
is anyone being is everyone looking like
man it's not concord right right regular
grape yeah it would be okay
well there's white grape and then
there's red grape
why's it got to be a white grape
just saying all grapes matter
i sidelined us from the elon musk talk
oh sorry we're all over the road here
hey dude elon i don't know why
everybody's so upset because i'm like we
don't know what's going to happen yet i
think that's the whole thing it's like
why don't we just wait and see we don't
know if he's going to make it better we
don't know if he's going to make it
worse
can it get worse
a lot of funny when people were like why
is a rich guy gotta buy twitter and
you're like i don't think the people who
own it right now are dirt poor i don't
know
good point
also bezos bought washington post
everybody nobody seemed to care about
that i think people cared about that oh
did they okay you know i feel like i'm
seeing more heat on the on the twitter
buy
i mean people just need [ __ ] to be mad
about it they really like it it's like
man you know bezos is like thrilled
because he's like where do people [ __ ]
about me twitter cool i'll buy it i know
and they'll keep bitching about me
love it
this is activity yes it's more press for
twitter this gotta be the most expensive
vanity project of all time
like the pyramids i don't know have you
seen waterworld
[Applause]
i actually enjoyed that movie dennis
hopper but yeah yeah you're right this
is this is 44 bill we're in here 44 bill
just for ego
i mean maybe he thinks he can
spin this
what if he sells it for 48. well he's
obviously a smart guy he's got something
up his of his south african sleeve i
think i think something's cooking here
what do you think i don't know i don't
know but he maybe he'll just buy it and
burn to the ground just to be like hey i
own this yeah i've heard that i don't
think that's a smart financial decision
no here's 44 billion
it's probably not but he did say you
know how the algorithm is designed to
reward hate and fighting and feuding and
he said he's going to take that out
which is kind of nice because i feel
like this whole
country is being divided by just this
ah
don't be hilarious if like you just like
hope everyone has a great day and you're
like wow 45 000 retweets
yeah yeah exactly that'd be nice
but can it stand who knows no negativity
wins on these god-awful platforms i
think yeah i mean even if it's not
outwardly negative look what takes off
on instagram it's like it's not
something that's like hope everyone has
a great day it's like a woman jiggling
her tits or something sure well it's not
inherently good what we're doing i mean
look i don't hate it
but yeah tick tock what's popping off
it's like food and [ __ ] like that but
you mentioned a thing from tick tock
earlier what was your thing about uh you
said you saw something bourdain
yeah it was just positive some positi i
think two doc and instagram are
more positive than twitter for sure
because i think yes videos will be more
upbeat than just a quick
something about brevity on that and just
words i don't know yeah and it's it's
very for some reason people with twitter
feel
it's almost if you've got like uh
mental illness
what's the word uh concentrate you know
people are somehow willing to just talk
about their mental illness concentration
camp yeah that that was less less mean
than twitter more pleasant but yeah so
these people just will just open up on
twitter and be like i think this i think
that i'm crazy and i'm i'm willing to
show it yeah whereas in instagram you're
like oh it's a sunset that's a small dog
or a [ __ ] cat on a wheel
cats on a wheel dude can't beat it
[ __ ] love that [ __ ] are you pulling
up twitter porn right now i was all
right twitter's got a great porn yeah
we'll give them that bouncing boobs it
is weird you can just see like porn on
twitter like i think i follow one porn
star in there just because like
she followed me and i was like yeah
she's a famous porn show let me give her
a follow and then i'd be in line at the
grocery store it's like all joke joke
joke and then one porn star like
yeah
i'm like i'm a grastidis i can't i'm in
line what are you doing to me i know
when i got a drugged or whatever it was
the guy was my friend with me andrew
youngblood was like i'm like call my
agent we can't do the shows and he took
my phone and he put it up to my face it
unlocked it and then he's like
okay and porn just came up we started
laughing because that was the last thing
i looked at what genre were we doing i
think it was milf
milf is a go to it yeah i love bills
love milf milfs are great they like it i
want a woman having fun and milf seem to
be having fun and also i think like
young is just creepy to me like i can't
jerk off to a woman younger than me
really can't yeah it's weird to me i
know but you're getting older and older
so that your your window is closing i've
assumed it'll be 60 and up for me yeah
just got to keep it
something creepy about young women and
porn i don't like it well young
even 20s i don't want nothing to do you
don't want a 28 year old porn star
hmm i don't mind 28. give me someone
whose dreams are completely over that's
that's
safe i like that that's a genre yeah
that doesn't have to be milf i don't
want milf i want crushed dreams yeah i
want a bag lady or a cashier or uh you
know a lady who works at a like a sewage
plant no fall day for sure all right mil
what is it about milf why do we like
mills well our my mom was uh
rarely around
so maybe that's something
and you feel like you're giving back a
little bit like these milfs are probably
not what it is they're probably out
there i don't i don't know
here's what i think it is i'm never like
wait do you have any you have any unicef
it's not porn
i think milfs are like dudes in a way
they just want to get pounded and we
want to get laid there's no story
there's no [ __ ] there's no [ __ ]
what are we are we dating is this going
to be something is there a future no
we're trying to get laid yeah
i'm just like you're done they take a
puff of cigarette they're like get out
of here kid yeah time for that [ __ ] what
milk doesn't have time for that i love
that yeah that's hot they got to do the
dishes they've got a kid to worry about
yes they don't have time for this
[ __ ] go pick up your son from soccer
practice you who yes
and they want it and you want it the
character i was doing i would never
speak to a woman that way you're
pointing right at me point of you you
[ __ ] horse
yeah you're married to a milf
wait a minute
okay there you go i mean i i would i
just call her you know your wife stacey
yeah i would never call her a milf
marker
[ __ ] horrible what no he's asking is
it a compliment that's what's tough
about it i don't think they want to be
called a milf but you would like to also
you ever ever speak to someone and
they're like i'm a milf and like how old
are you like 34 and you're like oh come
on
i meant milf is supposed to be like mid
40s but if you were at your
daughter's or sons elementary school
picking them up and going back to your
house and and a lady was like oh sam mr
morill everybody thinks you're a dilf
yeah wouldn't you be flattered
no because i don't want to [ __ ] these
kids no no the the teachers saying the
teachers yeah
not the kids i mean these are
five-year-olds up there and everyone's
saying that you're a one hell of a sex
teacher
i throw it back on them
i i guess i think that's a
difference between men and women right
there is a dilf as the comment of milf
is like uh oh
where are we at here i mean look any of
it so you're like [ __ ] i'm old anything
that's just saying you're gonna be dead
soon doesn't feel great well
you could be a young mom i'll tell you
what's even worse you say you're a real
jilf
grandma yeah ah
but i think as a grandma you're like i'm
still [ __ ]
that's true i think there's a guy how
about how about a gilf
good elf is even more impressive
puerto rico we're gonna get there yeah
this 101 year old grandma loves to [ __ ]
by the way the oldest person on the
planet just died 118. 119. oh really my
baby was 112.
[Music]
oh man
well pull her up let's see tanaka i
think it was
yeah dude
asian yeah
yeah japanese maybe oh
is it 118 or 119. let's see
she's seeing stuff there she is oh yeah
there she is
one night what was your secret to
staying alive yeah they always have good
secrets i bet that but it's always some
it's always some horseshit where you're
like they're like every day i drank
bathtub gin and you're like i don't
think that
i think you might be an outlier i don't
know if that's i know it's all genetics
but they're like i shot heroin in my ass
every day and you're like oh maybe i'll
try that
tanaka
love to should we do let's do some news
stories man the news yes sir guess what
some [ __ ] news stories up in this
[ __ ] hell yeah oh look at you
you got your stuff stop looking at this
oh sorry
shout out to tanaka you'll be missed
118. stop asian what's the oldest you
bang
117.
[Laughter]
it depends on the colostomy bag i don't
know i don't know what's going on at
that age that's a whole i [ __ ] like
a me and a friend took a couple gals
home once from uh playwrights tavern and
they were they were
[Music]
pretty
i mean these were like
i don't know how they were i think they
got out of the asylum or whatever you
call the old folks home and had a night
out but uh they were old you hooked up
with them yeah and i remember banging
one and she had this crazy vagina and
she was like i got surgery on it for my
third kid and i was like ah nice this is
some good pillow talk here
what's that you described the vagina uh
well i was
going to town and it felt different it
felt uh filleted
if you will it felt uh fillet of fish
yeah
let's go to the news it was stretched i
can't describe it i was we were both
trying to god matt all right the
so-called croydon cat killer is alleged
to have killed and dismembered and
mutilated 400 cat hey we got guests oh
[ __ ]
surprise guest
what is this a sitcom
you're coming in
take that chair are we doing the are you
doing the bar i'm the whacky bartender
a drink he's not mike though man we need
to get him
oh yeah good point good point will you
look good you want to make us you want
to make us a drink up here and we need
some ice too then give you guys a drink
let's do it all right you got the
craziest jeans derosa first of all we
need uh
you drink every day you eat kfc and you
look amazing
on a diet
i've been on a diet i started eating
like clean food that i make myself
wow only drinking tequila and not
drinking every day
well done good for you we're about to
step up it's great to see you man
let's get him mike so we can get some of
this stuff this is good stuff
this is what this studio's turned into
it's just uh it's like a hub yeah well
i'll start making you guys a drink
though
please is there like rocks glasses or is
it all we're looking well you got two
right there you can use we just drank
out of those okay
come on at this point we all have we all
have hpv
he's getting the ice there but
sorry he's uh he's the british you know
what he signed up for yeah yeah we're
talking about the the cat killer
oh
okay yeah so the police carried out uh a
three-year investigation into the cat
killings but have yet to make an arrest
the killings are still happening whoa
how many cats have you killed it says
upwards of 400 mutilated wow
that's
it's like 3 600 cat lives right there
that's horrible
that's true
what is going on people want to kill
cats there's like a real epidemic where
people just
you know they don't [ __ ] with cats guy
would put them in a bag and suck the
arrow it's evil it's evil this guy's
murdered more [ __ ] than pete davidson
all right all right
now that's uh that's terrible that's you
can't you can't just kill cats yeah that
sucks yeah i mean i saw the play it was
pretty rough
but
they always land on their feet
they'll be fine
oh sorry
this poor guy's working overtime because
he's running an insane asylum here
everybody thinks a drinking podcast is a
good idea
to start producing it
well dude these guys coming in and i'll
be like yeah all right guys
dude this is the wacky neighbor i know
right good to have you and you have your
own bar and then you got to come here
and sling drinks hey it's all right it's
all right you know check out joey rose's
lower east side manhattan good good
sandwiches what do you guys want a
whiskey i don't know whatever you keep
it going with whiskey because we had a
couple of whiskeys earlier oh it's a
little gentleman jack is that what we're
doing
it's a single barrel jack daniels
that's the good stuff you can tell by
the fancy bottle
give you a little on ice there's
something floating in these glasses
already that's pretty gross
that's my career
it's all over
floating
i don't know what it is but i'm not
looking forward to this drink as much as
i was the earlier one
i don't blame you dude look at this
mount gay what is that that's that's
where accused lives
[Laughter]
um i don't see any tequila over here my
i'm it's gotta be something oh here's
reposado hey
come join sit down right there next to
salakis after you i am i'm just going to
pour a drink first what'd you do with
ari
he
this [ __ ] kid he left he's like we
got to do this we got to do that or he's
the kind of guy that's like do you want
to hang out tomorrow and you're like
yeah and then you have to call him like
yeah so what is the plan that you have
to make right what's your idea so i get
here i'm walking into the studio
he's like
i'm shit-faced i'm going to get pizza
let's wait 20 minutes before we crash i
go no i'm here i'm crashing now
i go
then he caught me out there he said wait
wait wait wait wait don't go in yet
i go why do i have to go in when you go
and he's like okay you're right you're
right i'm sorry i'm so then he went and
got pizza see this is the part i already
no one knows about you know the bathrobe
shaky old man ari it's uh it's all fun
and games he's in china he's he's uh
this is not happening he's dosing bert
but he's actually i need a break i can't
handle it i'm wearing a diaper thank you
thank you over here
let's do another news story all right
he's already another one
we have two different sets of news
stories so we're going to do one of the
other episodes mike right there oh he
might be with this thing oh you're fine
are we good with just that then you like
him here matty you want him on the bench
okay the georgia man a georgia man is
accused of stuffing his grandmother in
the freezer
and leaving her there to die she wasn't
dead i guess wow robert tincher iii
told police that he heard numerous bones
break when he put his 82 year old
grandma in the freezer whoa
jesus christ he's picking these stories
yeah these are matt what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you holy [ __ ] what are you
doing here that's a horrible story
grandmother that's a big freezer though
you got to hand it to this guy or she's
a tiny woman oh that's true i think it's
both right you know you got a little
grandma in a large freezer
i bet you it's a region freezer which is
a term i learned after i opened a
sandwich that's the freezer on the floor
where you open the lid like a [ __ ]
coffin oh
i know those that's what the guy in uh
do you ever see that movie with um jack
black um where he kills his where he's
married to shirley maclaine and he kills
her no oh that's a great movie yeah the
richard linklater movie true story yeah
yeah he put his wife in her in a
reach-in freezer right he could like fit
a body in it and he was like everybody
loved him in the neighborhood he was
like a town hero and they turned out to
be a [ __ ] psycho
weirdly fun considering how dark it is
dark there's a real guy
texas guy yeah there you go
damn
i think he sold cars
he
no he ran a funeral home ah
he ran a funeral home and um
it was an odd it was an odd tale most of
the people it's one of those movies
where they do it like um docustyle like
and they enter you know like all the
scenes are cut in with interviews
and um
actually you know do you know dudley and
bob the the radio guys in austin yeah
dale dudley yeah yeah
he's in it he's like one of the people
in the interviews
and i was talking about and i go dude
some of those people are some of the
best actors i've ever seen i was like i
don't even know who they are but they're
so real and he was like no dude those
are real [ __ ] oh wow that like knew
the story and [ __ ] he just he goes he
just mixed it in with like actors
how do you think you're going to get
away with that by putting someone in the
freezer it gets away with it for a while
yeah until you're going for tater tots
once you're like i can't take it
she's hated his wife is hated yeah so
like he gets away with it for a while
and why is she so much older than him
that's part of the weirdness of it he
like seems gay
she was rich
yeah she's rich like it's a very strange
like story yeah but that was yeah
link later is from austin i want to say
i believe so because uh daisy confused
is austin so it's slacker right so it's
slacker he's all about austin he was on
austin before austin was austin
he's one of the reasons i moved to
austin no you moved to austin i lived
there for a year um when i got out of
college i studied tv production in
college
yeah and i thought i was gonna do that
for a living i thought i was gonna
i don't know [ __ ] edit or i don't
know something yeah so i moved to austin
to do independent film because it was
when that boom was happening and and the
two guys out of austin where link letter
and robert rodriguez had just put out
desperado
whoa
um so i thought i'll go to austin and i
got there and they were like yeah buddy
get in line
everybody wants to work on these movies
still a fun town though i mean for a
young young derosa that's a fun place to
meet gals get drunk and eat tacos yeah i
had a blast made lifelong friends hey
there you go yeah it's it's i don't
regret it at all good for you i i
commend anybody who goes somewhere and
in in attempts of a dream you go to new
york you go to l.a you go to austin you
go to chicago whatever it is you went
for it depends on your dream if you're
slamming women in freezers it's a shitty
dream yeah yeah
it's a bad dream that's true
maybe his grandma was a [ __ ]
all right let's lighten the mood to this
next story all right
transgender riker's inmate raped a
female prisoner
women's section of the jail and has been
sentenced to seven more years ah that's
it
yeah seven years for so it's a it's a
dude
who's a transition to a woman still has
this pain at her penis and but went to a
women's prison and raped a woman wow
there's no good option if you're trans
in prison
there's just not really a good option
yeah no
i mean but what's [ __ ] up is now like
they're gonna let her stay in a female
prison i know right like that's exactly
the thing everybody
that i mean like i get it when people
are like stop worrying about [ __ ]
happening it's not gonna happen but this
is the rare case where it did happen you
gotta send her now to a man's prison but
then she's going to get raped like crazy
oh yeah there's no win here but here's
himself you want to you want to go to a
female prison you got to cut the dick
off that should be the rule all right
mark 20 24 who pays for it
the state's the
and we keep the dicks
or you gotta have a chicks with dick's
prison
oh you gotta have a section now that's a
porn yeah edward
prison this is like juwanna man meets oz
this is a
she goes by diamond blunt
i'm sure this is a hasidic jew obviously
or an asian i like how they sentenced
her like seven more years of raping it's
like your reward your punishment is a
reward yeah yeah you're back in the hen
house
this is damn good what is this
barrel
yeah good whiskey i don't like my that i
don't like what i poured sometimes a
tequila has too much of a vanilla flavor
i agree that's the case yeah we might
have something else that's fine i'm a
big boy i'll finish it
it's here to do a job i mean it's not
you know
this is a it's such a happy dropping i'm
so happy to realize
i'm happy to see you guys i'm thrilled
you look great i'm thrilled thank you
you both do as well and you guys never
really looked bad so well you're one of
the few guys who's down for a hang most
people go hey you want to do this and
they go i got eight shows i got a
podcast i got a i got to travel and
you're like what time
yeah i i i always held the hang is as
important as the work
you're here which is why you know we
combine the two yeah i work
i you know what though that's what i
always liked about you you guys like you
guys were part of a
you know we talked about this a little
bit last time i was here but you guys
were sort of part of the class like i
felt like right after my class like
and your class had
a much more um
i don't flipping sounds negative i don't
mean it negative but a much more
flippant approach to the worry
yeah i can't think of another word but
you weren't quite as concerned about
showing up to shows like drunk and
having fun yeah yeah i envied it because
when i started like there was a lot more
sober guys and squares really
well dude i came up under
oh well first of all they were sober
guys but you had the extremes you had
this the [ __ ] animals you had the
attells and the stanhopes and the
geraldos well they were the they were a
clash ahead of us okay but attel and
stanhope and geraldo who i did hang out
with many times
they were not the the norm like they
were they were sort of the rarity like
the guys are all prolific as [ __ ] for
guys who did that they were even more
rare they were they were and then also
too though the guys that i that were the
class immediately ahead of me that i
looked up to none of them drank patrice
didn't drink
um depalo didn't dr you know if he
didn't drink he didn't drink but he
didn't drink all out
colin didn't drink uh he had birth bobby
didn't drink burr started me and burst
started to drink together wow but burr
would always blame me for making him
drink
which you know but like he was not a guy
so my point is is like
and the guys in my media class jay
didn't really drink right uh marina
didn't drink like this it just wasn't
around and then i was always env
most of my hanging was done with you
guys it would be i would hang with you
guys and soda and right nate nate yeah
you know and uh i remember you like
showing up to caroline's like i'm so
hungover [ __ ] it like i was like man i
wish i had the balls to do that like
i would like hide it really oh really
yeah i would always be scared and it was
so bad sometimes i couldn't hide yeah
caroline's also this the free booze was
like i mean they would make whoever was
bartending there would be like a legit
like johnny or whoever would be
bartending there'd be like oh there's
like a good bartender i'm not [ __ ] up
oh yeah that was the land of milk and
honey that place louie was the guy
yeah louie was the puerto rican guy that
bartended at caroline
he was sort of a stocky guy with glasses
he was really boisterous yes he would
spin and dance and stuff as he was
making drinks like he was the [ __ ]
man
yeah that stairwell i used to walk down
and be like this is gonna be great it
was so exciting you were in midtown it
was that you know you're going to the
diamonds all different colors and that
green room we own that place and now i
go down there i'm like what is this a
museum it's a library yeah
you could smoke cigarettes on the green
room and it was a [ __ ] it was crazy
uh we got the we got the tail end of the
of the wild west i mean we got the tail
end of it we caught the tail end i
remember going out with a tell in the
east village oh before
like i'm oh my god like just you were
going into the depths of [ __ ] hell
like at 5 00 a.m the last the last
remnants of like the after hours yeah
mars bars yeah um he'd like bang on like
a sliding garage door and they'd slide
it open and let us in
what's the password yeah like wild i've
been making out with chicks i just met
doing coke with them and [ __ ] it was a
scene man it was [ __ ] the city's
losing its edge man
i was i was coming back
i was leaving a bar like [ __ ] closed
the bar this last weekend it's four am
trying to get a cab there's no [ __ ]
yellow cabs left for some reason it's 60
dollars like an uber two miles yeah so
so i'm like just waiting guys are
stopping in the street a guy goes uh all
right how far i tell him where i'm going
he goes it's 50 bucks i go that's it's
two miles dude it's 5 a.m he goes he
goes he goes [ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ]
i go
and i go i go [ __ ] you i'm hammer like
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] we're both
going at each other because you [ __ ]
cheap piece of [ __ ] and i was like forty
dollars and he goes all right [ __ ] you
forty dollars as i'm getting he goes
plus tip i'm like you [ __ ]
so funny dude dude what did you give him
41. i wouldn't do it whoa we kept
fighting i kept walking yeah that's all
right and then i ended up taking an uber
for 65. yeah he showed me the principal
i've tried congestion fee they call they
there's a peeve
they charge a congestion fee at 5 a.m
outraged what could unless the guy had
covered there's no [ __ ] congestion
what part of town were you going to i
was going to mid upper west mid
basically lincoln center area and
they're [ __ ] where were you in the
like the village it was like 15th street
that's not even two miles not even two
that's insane two miles yeah i should
have trained it at that point i should
have like 5 a.m and i was [ __ ] i
wouldn't [ __ ] around that time on the
train not these days there was a time
that's true the trains are wild now
[ __ ] up to us on the train yes
show himself he's gonna [ __ ] it up
get a little [ __ ] a little pepper
spray going yeah
yeah not [ __ ] around anymore get that
knife out don't let that hawaiian shirt
fool you he's not easy breezy you see
him doing a hawaiian shirt take a knife
out you're stepping back oh
yeah
yeah that's like hunter thompson [ __ ]
yeah
that's awesome i have a big knife under
my bed now
like a i have like a [ __ ] rambo
handle i have a rambo knife under my bed
because i was like i need something in
here in case somebody yeah you know like
it's [ __ ] nuts it's possible now yeah
it's [ __ ] wild yeah also a good way
to get rid of a lady after one night
stand like have you seen my knife
collection
no this city's gone down the [ __ ]
toilet i love it still but god damn what
is happening
it's my favorite place on planet earth
like it i'll never you like it like this
when it's dicey a little thunderdome
it's all right i like it always it's
exciting i feel like we're in a grand
theft auto video game and it's kind of
fun to see like it does feel like you're
going up against the boss every once in
a while you're like this dude's [ __ ]
dangerous yeah you don't know which way
to go just my brother were trash in the
city my brother and i are sitting on
house this city's gone downhill right as
we're staying in the west village we
just see a dude chasing another dude
with a pipe and i was like that's kind
of fun yeah keeps it keeps you engaged
yeah you got bad atd dude the pipe
chases you you're gonna focus yeah no i
i
agree i i
i like it in all
variations since i've lived here
and um
i do want more than ever now i would
like to buy
a place in like the stick somewhere
so i can go from one extreme to another
yeah when i need to that seems good but
that said i can't imagine there will be
a time in my life where i don't have
something in this city that i'm renting
or spending time here like i just can't
imagine it it's the best
place in the world i say this about
austin i say it about new york um
there are very few other cities i would
say about
no matter how um uh homogenized it
becomes or or how much things go
sideways or downhill it is still light
years beyond any other of course of
course and i love i love i love philly
there's a lot of other cities i love
billy's great chicago is great yeah
there's a lot of them but like fun
austin yeah it's just like this is one
of those places where it's like no
matter what happens you're still
it's just the [ __ ] best the best
somebody put it well when pandemic was
happening i think it was ian lara and he
was like people were like the city's
changing everybody's moving out and he's
like new york doesn't care it's always
gonna be here it's always gonna be the
best
it goes up it goes down but
it's not changing you know it's the same
[ __ ] it's it's just it's just new york
it really is it's like when people say
i'm [ __ ] out of here it's like in new
york it's like new york is gonna be okay
even with the office space everyone's
like what about the offices new york
will find a way to survive trust me yeah
yeah it's it's something yeah it's like
a part the city's like a part of nature
at this point yeah it's like you know it
was an ecosystem oh the offices are
going down guess what those will get
turned into apartment buildings
something will happen where words
survive yeah or like or like the world's
first 36th floor nightclub or something
yeah
something insane
dude you got to go to floor 33 it's
crazy
but no dude that's that's i swear to god
that's i'm not being uh modeling or or
poetic or anything i i swear to you this
is true
that is the sentence that started
uh me opening joey rose's with paul
italia we were sitting on his roof we
were looking at the closed buildings and
he said
he said joe mark my words the survivors
are the ones that stay everybody jumping
ship forget it don't pay attention to
that the people that are going to
survive here are the ones that stay and
and see it through and he goes so if you
ever had an idea now's the time whoa
that was literally the sentence and the
sentiment that started it so it's
exactly what we're saying it's like
someone's saying the same thing in
ukraine right now he's like today's the
day we opened a sandwich
we need a sandwich here at the cupcake
place this is it
you're totally right dude i love these i
can't believe i still haven't been there
we're gonna go we've gotta go great
it looks great in there you just wanna
when you get in you just want a high
life and a shot yeah yeah yeah that's
what we wanted it to be
uh one seven four [ __ ] then folks
tuesday through sunday maybe maybe we
manned up there at some point tonight
yeah it'd be nice i'm down down um i got
11 o'clock at the cellar oh dear god
which room
bu what was that sound that you just
sorry i went all over the place you were
a duck at least
vu is not a bad one at 11 p.m on a
tuesday yeah that's fine
i like vu i like viola i mean i like all
the rooms lighting looks beautiful in
there now too it's like you get a tape
from there you're like this looks
[ __ ] beautiful yeah it's a good uh
it's a good that's a great room they're
all good but like it hurts sometimes
you're like i got a 1am at the black cat
bar
yeah
that's a tough one in between in between
setups here
all right here can you make that
cocktail a little less loud please
i'm trying to pursue my dream the worst
is when you do the vu you kill it you go
up to the fat black which is eight feet
away vertically and you eat [ __ ] it's
the same material eating [ __ ] yeah and
the vu is always spitting in the black
cat's face because you're hearing the vu
music playing as you're on stage at the
black hat that's true so the vu really
throws its nuts around bu is pretty epic
vu
vu and mcdougall are the two best
they're my two favorite rooms
i actually like v and
for that run of rooms i actually prefer
village underground
the vu and the blackout lounge the
lounge is good i have grown too well
when you're doing this
great well the hour's all right yeah
i've really grown to love the lounge and
i love the downstairs room with this
there's so many bombs those are my
favorite places
i've run
once i saw colin quinn would run hours
there i would always beg liz i was like
i feel like after colin i was one of the
first guys to just beg to run hours in
there sure how else am i gonna write in
the city and uh i would just bomb there
so much so i started to [ __ ] hate the
room but it was it kept you honest
i used to bomb there until they made it
a legit regular room and then something
in the air in there changed when it was
just a monday night room to like do your
uh would they call it jokes
by the way shout out to wilson vince for
starting that show will's been on the
show before i mean started a show that
literally was like hey new yorkers
[ __ ] bring new material like
encourage us to write
[ __ ] yeah dude yeah ironically all the
people who need to write are never there
but you know who you are that is
interesting isn't it yeah yeah that is
interesting
um but yeah those there's there's still
some great comedy rooms in the city like
like i like all of gotham but downstairs
at gotham i love that little room
downstairs i love it i love guys
downstairs at the stand i love yeah vu
lounge
i like the seller don't get me wrong i
just prefer the vu and then the la the
black cat lounge
uh i love new york comedy club oh
especially at 4th street too i love that
room but uh both new york comic booms
are pretty they're both kill rooms
they're great yeah those are those are
awesome rooms and then after that you
know like caroline's is a good
headlining room i don't [ __ ] around i
don't go you guys go to the strip or
stand you i don't ever go i don't do
private shows strip really blew it
because they had adam sandler and jerry
seinfeld used them in their specials and
they didn't parlay that into anything
it's like people were showing up
tourists were showing up like this is
the room right and they didn't parlay
that and like i mean i just did west
side comedy club and it was pretty good
if it's full it's great i like it yeah
you get a cool crowd it's like that jewy
upper west side crowd i love it i like
okay i never did it before it's a good
layout i'd open for bill bur there once
it was sold out it was bananas but it's
his people all right it was it's a cool
room nice you know and gina ran it for a
minute junior yes she works at the
cellar now yeah yeah who knows she's all
over the road yeah david tell it the
best line on her she's worked at so many
clubs he just walked up to her and he
goes eighth club's the charm
[Laughter]
she was dying she was laughing so hard
like man that is so good he just can't
not turn out gold the guy cuts deep he
cuts real deep
one sentence he'll cut you to the core
yeah yeah jesus christ man oh my god
that's so [ __ ] funny so good holy
[ __ ] she told it to me i was like god
damn that's good that's good and it's
simple
uh
eighth club's the four words it also
shows that how aware he is he saw her oh
she worked here she worked here and you
were here and he put it all together and
put it out in force four words that's
love right there dude burning someone
like that is love that's love i'm paying
attention to your life and i'm teasing
you you got that right that is love i
got a nork i got an orc i got all right
hey quick
i got a mark norman joke oh i ran this
bio years ago it's just a premise so
there's no punch lines
but the punch line i mean the premise is
perfect the impression the cadence is
perfect i'm not gonna be able to do the
voice very well all right but this is a
perfect mark norman bit
premise with no punch lines ready
you're gonna remember this i think when
i do it ready i was doing this in the
shower
today do you wanna know what i was doing
in the shower earlier yeah uh uh
uh
premise is clothes shopping
okay yeah
do you ever go to the bargain rack geez
that stuff is cheap do you ever go to
old navy whole store's the bargain rat
did you ever know the bargain rack at
old navy did holy hell they're giving it
away that's not bad that's a perfect
mark norman premise
there's no punch lines as i said i'll
take it i'll take it that you're you're
close you got one line away and that's a
killer bit there's just guys the old
navy you don't know the new navy is
charging yeah yeah you gotta add the i
don't know how to write jokes like that
how about this how about this okay
bargain rack bargain rag i went to the
bargain rag at old navy it was old army
all right all right i don't know i'm
thinking i'm spitballing here but i like
where your head's at all right i saw
emmy blotnick on stage the other day she
goes uh she's walked up and she's like i
don't know i'm thinking about buying
twitter and i was like oh i wish i
thought of that that's a great one
i loved little lines like that did you
ever see what uh uh brendan walsh used
to go on stage
it worked every time he would go on
stage and he would open with you go
jesus
i do you got
you don't know because you're in the
show gene hackman just died i love him i
love that yeah the audience would be
like
then he'd be like i'm just [ __ ] with
you and it would get this huge laughter
i was like and i'd be like none of you
realize how much you love gene hack yeah
he didn't conan he killed on conan yeah
jesus christ i also how the hell is gene
hackman so he is 90 something he's still
going going and he's just retired yeah
yeah he doesn't act anymore but he puts
out a
like a statement every few years where
he's like i'm doing good everybody i
just don't act anymore welcome to
mooseport will not define my end yeah
yeah right yeah he's great gene hackman
just [ __ ] ruled for so long but such
great movies oh gosh connection come on
french connection rules [ __ ]
unforgiven dude
conversation enemies royal tanning bombs
heist enemy the state's underrated i
never saw him that's a good movie yeah
with will smith yeah yeah pre-slap he
sort of like uh reprising his role from
the conversation that yeah pretty much
yeah
well done sally's his second to last
movie i think is
royal ten and bob's in this last movie
is
uh uh
welcome to mooseport right no runaway
jury there you go behind enemy lines
i don't know if that did well what was
runaway behind enemy line this is a john
cusack vehicle out of new orleans that
was when kuzak was still doing like
drama weighty stuff yeah uh by the way
he's got a great line and uh in tenon
bombs when danny glover is [ __ ] his
ex-wife and he comes up on him they like
beefing and it goes easy coltrane yeah
yeah yeah i love that line yeah yeah
that's like a nutella yeah no that's
that's so funny the uh well technically
his last movie is the release of the
richard donner cut of superman too so he
went out on top all right all right
there you go
mooseport ooh yeah yeah luther for
christ's sake yeah i just got the box
set get shorty was killer oh that's
right this is a really good run right
here
wyatt earp quicken the dead come on uh
oh yeah bird cage right uh postcards
from the edge bit of a dark period here
another woman that's a great woody allen
movie hoosiers
classic classic we haven't even hit his
like she re-watched it though you're
like this white team is not winning this
game yeah let's be real that's fantasy
you're doing running jump shots this
black team would [ __ ] kill you yeah
yeah come out of the rings was easier to
swallow that's so funny the uh the
poseidon adventure this guy's been there
holy [ __ ] that's an honor wait who the
hell is he in young frankenstein yeah
who is he i don't know i mean look it up
he's not he's not the monster scroll up
that's peter boyle
blind oh that's right he plays the blind
oh yeah one of those few main movie
stars who wasn't traditionally good
looking yes like leading men types i
mean like like de niro i guess dustin
hoffman you could say also is not
traditionally good looking but
true but he's cute he's got a full head
of hair he's a cute jewish well you know
he was originally gene hackman was
originally mr robinson in the graduate
whoa
and he got fired because he uh
he i think dustin hoffman mike nichols
played mind games with you and and
hoffman's like i'm gonna get fired no
gene hackman's like no i'm gonna get
fired and he's like no you're what are
you talking about you're great and he
goes i'm too young he's like i'm like 10
years older than you i shouldn't be
playing wow mr robinson and nichols was
like get him out and he fired him
nickel seems like he was a dildo he was
a real dick i think a genius but a dick
i think
he yeah i think he was a very brilliant
guy but like i've seen the interviews
with him like later in life and the way
he was talking i was like oh i don't
think i would have liked you're like the
original like alt comic like you're so
sensitive about everything right the way
he did that movie with gary chandling
where he played the uh the alien
remember in the 90s yeah what planet are
you from dude he wouldn't let him do
like
extra takes i'm like you're dealing with
a [ __ ] great community really yeah
and you're [ __ ] the movie up because
you're not letting them breathe the
movie sucks it sucks but i mean do you
only think it could have been maybe good
if it was directed by someone else yeah
well yeah or let let shandling and those
guys do what they're going to do exactly
i mean this is a great run here he has a
disease
made his hair fall out when he was like
six mike nichols so that's a piece
alopecia maybe geez better not joke
about that
or is there another thing that's like
alopecia i don't i thought it was
something else but it's it's a he's
wearing a wig
yeah i mean nickels who's afraid of
virginia woof do you ever see that movie
i gotta watch that's right catch 22 is
good
yeah this guy's on fire working girl i
jerked off to that regarding henry
henry bird cage damn i didn't know he
did primer cage
with travolta played oh he did closer
oh dude it's it's do you like do you
like philip schumer hoffman i love him
yeah i can't i haven't seen it bro it's
it is in my top five hoffman
performances really top three you gotta
what what are the other two
uh boogie nights and magnolia
uh i would go boogie arts and big
lebowski
such a small role though it is both fair
novels
uh you know it's an underrated hoffman
performance
mi3 as a villain oh yeah he's [ __ ]
amazing
wait what other philip give me the
philip seymour hoffman list i want to
write cody
yeah but it's not a i don't enjoy the
film though
it's a good movie i'm saying though like
for for my favorite philip seymour
hoffman performances
i'm not putting capote oh i love uh
god's pocket do you ever see that before
the devil knows you're dead yes awesome
one god's person that's what i call my
uh yeah i saw that one
yeah charlie kaufman my therapist was
that movie god's pocket is great john
tuturo philip seymour hoffman and uh
richard jenkins
[ __ ] [ __ ] love richard jenkins
best post 911 movies
25th hour and the visitor richard
jenkins and the visitor amazing yeah um
for like that 9 11 post 9 11 i'm gonna
give all right my top three i'm gonna
give boogie nights
don't say twister i won't say hey oh
[ __ ] with the shirts
how do we do this mic wise uh peters we
might be drunk is thrilled to welcome
our new sponsor fanimal
i love live events i hate buying tickets
the hidden fees suck and coordinating
with your friends is the nightmare
they're garbage i always end up fronting
a bunch of money and chasing down my
friends to get reimbursed not me
personally because i'm very generous if
they flake i'm stuck with a whole bill
and then i discovered fandable fandible
has tickets to everything there's no
fees the price you see is the price you
pay that's i mean that's pretty big yeah
not only those prices transparent but
they're almost always lower than
anywhere else i look and for any hot
ticket like coachella a laker game or
dave chappelle fanimal is always the
cheapest option nobody gives nobody goes
to live events anymore so why buy
tickets alone fanimel although if you do
come to a show alone there's nothing
wrong with that honestly i love that
someone tweeted me about that the other
day they're like i wanna is it weird my
friend's bails are weird if i come alone
i said no dude enjoy yourself yeah and
you know what the guy made new friends
at the show they tweeted me afterwards i
sat with these guys and they were
tweeting me too so you end up having a
great time no matter what um
fanimal's patent group purchase makes it
easy first you set a minimum size for
your group and you choose the number of
tickets you want to pay for yourself
then you invite friends when the minimum
size is met everyone gets charged and
receives their ticket if the minimum
size isn't reached in time nobody gets
charged you don't commit until your
friends you march tell them how mark i
called you march
march march normand tell them how to do
it oh yeah and family has amazing
customer service don't take my word for
it check out their hundreds of five star
reviews the next time you need tickets
go to fanimal.com and sign up with
code drunk
for 20 of credit 20 of credit towards
your first purchase we drink on this
show check out fanimal and experience
more
support the show and get 20 off your
first purchase with the code drunk at
fanimal.com f-a-n-i-m-a-l
dot-com get on hey
we might be drunk is brought to you by
lucy you're a responsible consumer and
you want a responsible way to consume
your nicotine don't you
well if you're looking for nicotine gum
lozenges or pouches to use nicotine to
relax focus or just unwind after a long
day there's only one stop you should
make
lucy
i like this stuff the gum tastes great i
prefer the lozenges because you just
throw them in you're not smacking around
town with the chewing so uh get on it
plus you know
it just tastes good then it gives you a
little jolt that yeah oh yeah it gives
you a kick if if i'm hungover
i pop one of those in and i'm like
pretty good it's the least healthy
endorsement of all time also if you're
going to the casino hitting the slots
just chew the gum and you get the same
the nicotine without having to kill your
lungs
so you've been looking for an
alternative to smoking why not switch a
nicotine product that can actually make
you feel good and feel good about doing
it tell them how fatty if you enjoy
using nicotine you should definitely
check out lucy's products at lucy.co
that's lucy.co promo code drunk at
checkout also i have to read this
disclaimer warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical remember if you're interested
in a better way to use nicotine visit
lucy.co and be sure to use that promo
code drunk
hey folks we might be drunk is brought
to you by factor
if you can't stand the heat get out of
the kitchen factor is here to give you
delicious healthy meals that are ready
in minutes with factors spend less time
in the kitchen more fun in the sun it's
fresh never frozen prepared super good
delicious you won't believe and they're
good for you
with 30 meals offered each week you'll
never be bored with your meal plans each
meal arrives pre-prepared and ready to
eat in two minutes that's faster than
getting a pizza
look at all they got they got vegan
veggie meals low calorie options juices
smoothies
energy bites plant-based bars
extra protein and veggie size to every
meal they sent me a bunch they were
great it's really good it's really good
i went every day i'd give them to the
lady she's a food snob she liked it
those smoothies are incredible
nice just having the house coconut milk
so good
so ahead to go.factor75.com
drunk120
jesus christ
so that's
go.com sorry go dot factor
drunk120 to get 120 off
damn drunk 120.
it's good i really liked it i mean i
think very good in my freezer just for
you never know when you want a quick
two-minute uh heat up you know exactly
yeah so that's code drunk120 at
go.factor75.com
drunk120 for 120 off healthy eating made
easy get on it buying a home is
overwhelming if meeting with realtors
and endless open houses aren't enough
once you do find your dream home you're
suddenly expected to know how to
navigate the mysterious world of banking
bureaucracy
i mean you know this is a pain in the
ass the paperwork buying a home
you know luckily there's mortgage cs it
works with you to find the perfect loan
program for your situation most mortgage
lenders will try to push you through the
process without showing all of your
options not mortgage cs mortgage cs
works for you not the banks and not the
real estate agents they show you a full
range of options not like those other
lenders their top priority is earning
your trust and putting your financial
best interest first not their bottom
line
with evening and weekend availability
their service is second to none that's
why cs in mortgage cs stands for
concierge service visit mortgage cs dot
com slash comedy to schedule a call
today you can also call or text their
ceo ben right now take out your phone
dial 267-391-7425
anytime or day any time of day or night
including weekends for the vip treatment
just mention the drunk sent you and
he'll hook it up not convinced google
mortgage cs and read over their 200
five-star reviews wow
this sounds pretty good yeah
o r t g a g e c s dot com slash comedy
to get the concierge service you deserve
the advertisement is not commitment to
lend or extend credit
mortgage cs is an equal housing
opportunity mortgage broker all loans
are subject to credit approval certain
restrictions may apply company nmls
number
fourteen
six four seven six six
visit mortgage cs dot com slash comedy
for more information
nice
all right i'm gonna say boogie nights um
happiness nah it's too gross uh
it's too gross uh
whoa i like that which one did i just
say oh oh charlie wilson's war yep
and i might go state in maine as my
third i saw when i was too young i don't
think i appreciated it enough it's
mammoth right it's heavy it's mammoth
yeah
oh no but that was baldwin's in it and
stuff mr ripley yeah that's balling [ __ ]
16 year olds in it that's like his
advice they had to keep covering it up
man it's got a new movie out now right
who mammoth no no he's got his play is
uh american buffalo going thursday night
oh yeah sam rockwell paul i mean and
lawrence fishburne i'm going thursday
night 7pm
no no matt get out you need your
computer all right holy [ __ ] what else
is above stay in maine on the imdb
stomach this is amy man
that's a good one oh punch drunk glove
he's great but again small roll patches
oh along came polly
right now
hold on i got to give along king paulie
it's props she's amazing in that movie
does this scratching of his [ __ ] back
hair ah against this guy's chest oh it's
amazing no that's not him though that's
another stranger with candy oh
basketball
playing against it's not phillips you
were often but phillips robin is equally
as disgusting in that movie like get
that up alley
right his face was against the guy he
keeps going he kills he keeps going
swish and they're nothing man
[Laughter]
you know what actually we're kind of in
the middle of a conversation
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude is this manhattan
yes
or it's supposed to be at least i don't
know i love a ball hog who sucks yes
her rain drops
old school what makes it even better is
his form is kind of right yeah and it's
still horrible also the shot they're
showing is so off in the shot he takes
it's like a slam against the backboard
he has arc man he's good whatever
happened to him
he didn't know that your tolerance goes
down
she's really cool she did this
she's the
uh
annie hall
staple hannah hannan her sisters is my
favorite movie of all you love that
movie really yeah that's a great about
you
uh um um
uh love actually jesus
i want gay polly what do you think you
got a few
anything with drew barrymore high
fidelity high fidelity that might be the
best one of all time
that's a good one the tv when harry met
sally's great show was awesome
amazing that's a great movie yeah it's
amazing classic shots classic shot
rob what else they suck they suck palm
springs is pretty good too much rom not
enough calm right
calm is out good point something about
mary is technically a rom-com it's so
good that's a great move yeah oh that's
my favorite wedding singer's great
wedding singer's a good one you know
what's a decent comedy is saving
silverman yeah it's good yeah i like
shaving shoulders but yeah uh movement
of course yeah oh can't buy me love holy
[ __ ]
what a premise he goes and [ __ ]
housewives say anything the remake of
can't buy me love with just nick cannon
just the black cam by me love what
you're a remake yeah nick cannon did it
really kevin christie was in it
can't hardly wait is a great one
he's crazy i love hit canon he's right
about the jews
dude the day after oh girl next door
the day the ukraine war broke out there
was a picture of nick cannon performing
at caroline's and i just retweeted i was
like can we get some good news today
and he just follows me right after i
tweet that oh my god can't you make any
jokes anymore without
without the lead of the masked singer
coming after you that's so funny man i'm
not anti-semitic i follow sam
[Laughter]
pretty in pink old john hughes rom-coms
were great yeah yeah pretty pink's a
great one they were teen rom-coms at
this point blank was great that's not a
rom-com that's just like a great movie
some kind of wonderful punch drunk love
is such a weird first point
is so [ __ ] underrated i think i might
love rom-coms well there's all these
numbers amazing dude there's some great
ones some bad ones when you were an
aspiring director
your first movie was always one of two
things is the apartment it was either a
heist ah
it is yeah i guess that's a great
rom-com which one which one the
apartment with jack lemmon billy wilder
moves i'll be honest with you i think in
its own way the odd couple is a rom-com
wow
it's a buddy movie but that's a bunny
movie yeah
it's a rom-com with no penetration mark
it's two guys that think they're not
going to make it making it in the end
okay okay
but
was um now oh that's not the kind
i don't know midnight run was a rom-com
the accused is a great race
schindler's list rom-com
beverly hills cop rom-com
wait what were we just trying what movie
we were just talking about though
no
along came polly are you drinking
straight tequila out of a martini glass
i am it's the only one i can find at
short notice there's many glasses up
there
what kind of pizza did you get
um kosher pizza whoa there's a kosher
pizza place right around here i was like
you're really running with this guy
it's really shitty
there can't be meat or cheese on it
there was one of the other cheese oh
yeah all right did you bury the plate
that's all i know about jewish buildings
you were a uh
a jewish hebrew school kid huh yeah
orthodox jewish you went all in all in i
went to seminary
yikes
israel two years old
how was it
great was it falafel incredible
the falafel was incredible and the bread
there's no uh it was just fresh every
day
damn falafel
how'd you dodge the army
uh don't tell them your father's israeli
that was the the prime directive do not
say your dad is from israel they will
draft you wow and get out before you've
been there for three years damn
yeah and claim you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm hungry now i'm hungry i kind of like
the the mandatory army thing i don't
want to do it but it's i think it might
be good for the it makes everybody feel
like you're part of the country exactly
in theory it's great in theory in theory
communism is great in the world theory
right hey in theory comedy's great
yeah that
that is true what a [ __ ] [ __ ] gig
hey we're having a blast right now we're
drunk oh this is fun this ain't comedy
this is podcasting this is what we
should have been doing the whole time
this is just drinking with your buddies
yeah speaking of which you got a special
uh your recording which we're all
confused about
i can explain i know i knew i was gonna
get [ __ ] for this i knew i was gonna get
[ __ ] for this but yes i'm shooting my
new hour special i'm proud of you in
houston at the coming ticket festival
uh man group yeah at the secret group
andrew youngblood is the venue yeah may
19th and may 22nd thursday and sunday
one show each night
come on out it's very few seats uh
200 theater in there not even i'm doing
no i'm doing the small room oh i'm doing
like the tight room 27 seats yes it's
going to be incredible is that we did
our show mark
huh is that where you did our uh skank
fish show
oh one of them will you jump around in
there no no our pre-skank fest show me
you and shane is that that room that's
the big room he's doing the small one
wow
yeah it's gonna be great so i'm doing
i'm doing thursday then i go to austin
and do four shows of the creek and cave
on that friday saturday gotta come back
to houston and do the second taping of
the special on the 22nd so it's gonna be
a weird thing but very cool so that yeah
that's it new hour it's called i never
promised you a rose garden oh that's
nice
poetic
it's about i saw it on a book and i was
like i'm going to call my special yeah
that's got the nice negative tone
[Laughter]
give you a sandwich but yeah i'm excited
but yeah so anyway that's all right
what got you just hunker down and go
[ __ ] it i'm doing an hour special
because i you know i like all of us
probably i had the skeleton of whatever
the hour was before
lockdown right sure
and
i you know slowly started to do comedy
again and and write some new things then
i went on the road and then when i went
on the road i remember sitting down one
day and being like
all right i'm gonna go [ __ ] crazy
like i need to write like 20 new minutes
to to like fill out what this
skeletal hour was sure because i'm
plugging all the holes with old stuff
and i had never released the other stuff
so i did that and it all worked and it
just congealed and all of a sudden this
hour that i was like iffy about from
before the pandemic became this much
more elevated thing nice that was very
proud of and i started doing it and it
was just working and i was like i i need
to do this i need to record this like
now like this is because it's very like
of the time it's very yeah you know and
that was it what are you playing man i
never promised you a rose garden
oh there you go i didn't even know it's
a song what a bomb outfit she has on i
would wear that should i dress like that
in the special yes
[Music]
yeah
i had to look at you to see if you could
pull it off but i think you can
it's going to be awesome look at those
jokes
who is this [ __ ]
i'm sure a lot of our listeners know
joe's stand up but he's hilarious
thanks guys i've been trying to get you
to stand up for 10 years
the one joke i always quote from you is
uh i think it might have been a
throwaway joke but it was uh everybody
talking about how great uh europe is
compared to america oh they've got this
they've got that it goes yeah you know
what they got in europe that we don't
have in america
ruins
[ __ ] europe there's no air conditioning
that's great it took me a second you
guys are sweet thank you i appreciate it
guys i love you i quote your bit about
uh tolerance all the time he's like
everybody thinks he's so tolerant
don't give it away it's like that's a
closer oh oh really yeah that's a great
[ __ ] oh that that oh yeah okay okay all
roads lead to that bit of stuff okay all
right broca's manager
the depression uh album you did the
profession auction
she said it was her favorite cd of all
time rogan's manager said that yeah it
doesn't mean you'll be on you won't ever
be on again but
that like she was like i loved it i
couldn't stop playing it i loved it so
much yeah where the hell has she been
she's handling a multi-hundred dollar
career are you still are you still
smoking marlborough reds is the question
no i quit smoking a few good for you
it's always rough when you see a young
guy with marlborough reds i was never a
reds guy though i was i was a winston's
guy for a minute winston oh what a [ __ ]
your head out of your ass winston's i
spoke with god for a while
you're not better than us
winston's are trash what are you talking
about sounds classy though yeah no
winston's i don't know
pull up winston which is a cigarette
that you pack on the back of a frame
those are wednesdays these are not
clashes what am i thinking
you're thinking of like dunhill yeah
yeah yeah dunhills are classic yeah
winston's are like where's the boys
i'll take it back
yeah
winston sounds like a waspy name though
it still sounds classy winston it sounds
like you're butler you know winston
spoke winston no he smoked winston's and
i know because i knew his daughter for a
while i was friends with his daughter
uh josh brolin smoked winston's that
she's the best she's so [ __ ] cool
she's super cool he was like he was in
the double marvel thing where he was
thanos but then he was also the bad guy
in uh deadpool yeah he was interesting
i had video i never met for as long as i
was friends with uh eden i never met him
but eden used to watch my dog when i
lived in l.a because we're friends she
would do me the favor and one day i was
somewhere and she was taking care of my
dog and she started sending me all these
videos and it was josh brolin playing
with my dog and i was like
a [ __ ] dog he's just spreading peanut
butter in his nuts like jesus
he was at the stand once just hanging
out and i went up to him and i was like
hey and i bombed horribly and i i was
like how about that show hon he was like
get away from me wow i bombed horror you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] it with bro i tried i
tried he gave me the the wave away it's
funny because brolin's not anyone we any
of us dream about talking to but when
he's there he's like oh cool oh yeah
he's a country man yeah dude i was there
one day
yeah
i could have said marriage instead of
banging that would have been nice
james brown i mean that's a legend dude
look at this james brolin's hair now
it's insane great
what's it called um i was there one
night terrible crowd
edie falco whoa
i went on stage had a decent set but the
one who was carrying it was edie falco
wow she was like yeah she was like
really laughing i was like that that
lady is awesome she gets it she gets
like what we're all [ __ ] going
through right now
i mean it was a rough [ __ ] crap
that's the only person when you see her
in the crowd that's like that's the only
person i care about isn't it funny when
you see she was a celebrity in the crowd
venus uh
williams was in the audience once at the
village underground and you could just
like everybody was like looking to their
left the whole time
she laughed was she having fun she was
having a blast venus williams
wow
that's awesome like snoop look at josh
brolin he looks like alan hayvey or that
hair dude tell me that hair is not
insane you only got barbra stress
because he looks like he's a good 401k
barbara looks like ron perlman
i love when people try to tell you a
young barber strandson was hot you're
like [ __ ] she had moments she was out
she had clear skin that's it she looked
like a [ __ ] big nose conker
she's pointing where she's headed she
does look like ari and ari's defense she
looks like
guess what he does i would [ __ ] a young
artist sophia
he had a career how weird is this yeah
how [ __ ] weird is this
i would say if i [ __ ] barbra streisand
this is not happening
i remember i asked eden once about it i
was like eating it's kind of weird like
i just realized this your grandma is
kind of barbra streisand
and i was like i know she's not like
you're like by blood grandma but she's
like your grandma by marriage and i was
like is that weird and she's like
well you know it's me she's just barbara
and i was like
like
even as many famous people as we've all
met you can't wrap your head i can't
wrap my head around of course who's the
weirdest person in the crowd where
you're like [ __ ] this messed me up
uh i had the lady from csi in the crowd
what's her name which one you know her
the the csi gal she's kind of milfie
uh
she's she's older she's pretty
abby crutchfield
no that's a comedian the lesbian one
the ladies yes i wear csi
susan sarandon that's her the first one
what's your name marge
marge helgenberger oh i thought she was
more famous elizabeth shue marge
helgenberger
dude i wouldn't even know who that lady
was
i saw her that she was glowing she was
in the crowd at uh jack john franklin's
joe franklin's
remember that [ __ ] disaster of a show
that's a bad picture
yeah she's she's clearly attractive i'm
just we have we're not the best you've
done you've done 400 000 shows this is
your this is okay well i did the patrice
benefit and adam driver was in the front
row was he laughing yeah he was awesome
one night in the belly room john bon
jovi was there with the guy from true
crime what's his name true detective the
the main one the the the the the the the
the the
the the the the the the middle
what mcconaughey
was bombed heckling everybody we'd all
finish our session we're like fun or no
not fun okay go to the green room judge
over come back go i'm really sorry for
my friend i really apologize one after
another he would come out and apologize
wow
they're being bombed
i [ __ ] bombed this is my worst one i
bombed at the boston comedy club in
front of inspector deck from wu-tang
clan
and he's my favorite wu-tang member
was your favorite i turned to him in the
middle of my mind you contrarian [ __ ]
jeff no i love inspectors
he's awesome he's awesome joe will
always be like what's the non-obvious
choice no no inspector deck is awesome
and we'll go here
ghost face that's who you go
in my opinion buries everybody the the
only copper i love the entire tank clan
dude i'm not [ __ ] on anybody totally
the only comparable lyricist in wu-tang
is method man
in my opinion he's got i gotta maybe i
don't know enough about it i said new
star wars more than the old star wars
like that's the most famous wu tang
versus oh that's him yeah that's
inspector okay anyway he was in the
crowd i was bombing so [ __ ] bad
oh this is very familiar yeah this is no
you know that all the songs from this is
the big one
m-e-t-h-o-d is the big one
this is pretty hard though
[Music]
all right cut it we gotta we don't pay
for royalty
i was bombing so bad i turned him in the
middle of my set and i go
deck i don't know what to tell you
and he left i believe during myself oh
he goes this guy's going to talk to me
afterwards i don't want to be here yeah
good save
[ __ ] damn ooh tank that's crazy yikes
hey guys where can people get these
shirts
we might be drunkpod.com we got that
right we got the glasses you like dude i
remember i was in tampa once middling
and it was years ago and so splitters
yeah and chris jericho is in the crowd
no the wrestler doesn't want to kill his
wife no that's chris benoit that would
have been a better story he was the man
that would have been a much better story
sam was like do something about your
life this motherfucker's gonna kill his
wife or some [ __ ] he's got bad energy
now uh
no uh crispin chris jericho was hammered
and years later he did my msg show he's
cool as [ __ ] really nice guy but he was
wrecked during the show and i was like
he's gonna [ __ ] ruin my set like i
think he's gonna he's so drunk he's
laughing so loud that it's like
i'm like dude i can't not address this
but i don't want to address it because
i'm a fan this is weird right and i got
off just as it was about to turn and i
was like thank god who headlined
uh a guy named tim wilkins oh wait i've
heard of him really good dude i moved so
many years ago he crushed i mean it was
like those road headliners road
headlines ec room headliners and you're
like happy to feature for murder yeah
before them
awesome i remember i was staying the
condo he was like come by to check on me
he would just be like how are you he was
hanging out he was an awesome guy and uh
there's tim wilkins yeah and he uh yeah
and i remember getting off being like
thank [ __ ] god yeah and
he he was he kind of came out at the end
just stumbling it was cool as [ __ ] wow
oh there he is i don't know
is that him yeah
oh wow it's amazing those be level
headliners that were like pretty much
all really cool oh he was awesome they
might have a bit of an alcohol problem
i don't think he drank i think it was
just you know but like they were all
pretty [ __ ] respectful and like hey
let me give you a little bit of advice
but otherwise do your own thing yeah he
told me a great story actually i
remember he told me uh he opened for
geraldo
many years ago jimmy geraldo or greg
gray okay great her older rivera he
featured for geraldo rivera and he said
geraldo just tore his act apart
and it [ __ ] made him go with the made
him like work his ass way harder he was
like man it was like the best thing
anyone ever did for me and you're like
man it's crazy
the hazing back no i don't even want to
call it hazing but i remember uh
jesse joyce telling me a story about uh
one time geraldo goes what's up with
your shoe let me see your shoe and they
were on the balcony of a of a hotel and
geroldis just threw it over the balcony
oh and jesse just like all right they
landed the pool and it's like i'm the
opener that's what you do it's so funny
because like this is funny it's like but
i actually have no way to get home now
yeah there's a lot of it's funny but
yeah and that's awesome it's funny but
now i have to go to the airport with one
shoe yeah if you do that joke somebody
you have to be like i'm i'm going to buy
you new let me buy you this
yeah like that's that's a real like come
on dude it's my [ __ ] even the
slapping that this is a very new york
thing is slapping the food out of
someone's hand on the floor that was big
it's big but also it's like [ __ ] but
it's like oh if you can't afford a size
beats like here's five bucks go get it
yourself [ __ ] but it's at least like
i'm not out money
i would never do it to a young kid that
couldn't afford it i would only do it to
like like a friend or like me you
wouldn't have to give me the money with
a young guy you'd have to get them i'd
only do it to a close personal friend
right
could you i mean do it like i did devos
in austin i was and we were both
laughing so [ __ ] hard you know what i
mean like it's funny yeah that's where
you're from i remember bobby just stuck
i forgot who it was he just took his
finger and stuck it in their drink and i
was like just so [ __ ] good
patricia at the jason anders we went to
jay's christening yeah at the comic
strip
classy guy
yeah
[Laughter]
who's christening to isabella's
christening at the con jay got his kid
ordained by god at the comic strip oh my
god i heard he got bumped by seinfeld
yeah
hold on ten minutes more
he got bumped by seinfeld's abortion
he's jewish the uh no but uh he uh
so um
we all went and uh jason indoors took
out the last piece of cake and patrice
and it was free cake like who cares yes
but patrice goes is this your cake is
that good and stuck his finger down into
it and jason anders was so mad he was
going to hit patrice that's the best he
was so man i was like jason it's like
free
baptism cake
if you're mad enough to strike someone
you've done the right thing
right getting him that man it's pretty
soul crushing though i was at a moon
tower years ago maybe south by and i was
looking at my notes and i had all my
jokes and bobby kelly swatted them all
they all went all went scattered and i
was like [ __ ]
this sucks older comic can't do [ __ ]
can't do [ __ ] make sure it's someone
your friend at least bobby you're
friendly with i had a guy do that to me
once while like it was like a comic i
didn't really respect and i wasn't close
to and he just smacked the notes out of
my hands i was like i don't even know
you dude i don't know you gotta know
where you are with the relationship
i in l.a when i first moved to la
and man he got like legitimately mad at
me i was at a i was at a party at ucb
for something and i was talking to kamal
nanjiani it was before he was famous
and uh he was a fun guy
yeah
and uh he had a book he had like a
notebook with him like a little notebook
i guess he was doing a set earlier and i
go hey can i see that and he handed it
to me and i threw it across the room
and he goes he goes go pick that up
right now
i love the line of this thing yeah dude
he got dead serious and he goes go pick
that up right and i go no and he goes go
back i go i'm not picking it up that's
the joke i'm gonna [ __ ] you without
picking it up and a girl that worked at
ucb
like saw it happen and went over and
grabbed it and came back and handed it
to him and she turns to me and she goes
real mature
and walked away
comedian i'm not mature and i was like
guys it was a joke like jesus christ and
he was like legitimately like mad at
that so get on all fours and get it with
your mouth jeff yeah
in my cast in pakistan that is the
biggest insult you can do
damn
that's hilarious joe is also one of the
best who always had really i thought
kumail's stand stand-up was really funny
because he did it he's hilarious
and he was fun when he when he was a
funded guy to drink i'm not speaking him
as a dude but no no not at all
and he is the guy to go to on advice for
steroid use
he
is
know what it's like to be in a marvel
movie or how to take steroids he is your
guy i love when he like showed his new
body he's like listen you got to be a
dietitian and and and work out i'm like
and
some people just don't [ __ ] with that i
saw ted alexandra once when i was brand
new i was at the cellar eating and i saw
ted sitting next to patrice and a couple
other guys and he was wearing a weird
sweater and they all went to town on his
sweater and he goes ah and he got up and
changed seats
he didn't like it i didn't know we could
do that like i didn't know that was part
of it
opt out and move
um
at least here's the thing at least ted
though just was like
that's not for me right yeah
he go he didn't go
i don't want to name names because i
like the guy but a guy
everyone seen we were making we were at
it i was at a table with keith and
norton and and there was another it was
at the seller and then there was another
table of comics who all worked there
and me and keith were like making fun of
their table
and i very loudly was like ah your table
stinks this is the better you know
whatever dumb stupid [ __ ] yeah and this
comic
um got up to go do his set and leaned
into my ear on the way downstairs and
goes you feel like a [ __ ] big man
it's all your [ __ ] comedy friends
because you'll do anything to be liked
right you'll do anything to be [ __ ]
like i walked downstairs and i was like
what the [ __ ] dude
and then he came up to me later and he's
like dude i'm sorry about that i was
just i'm i'm not in a good mood and i
was like yeah no [ __ ] dude like wow
comics do that a lot a lot of comments
i've had a lot of comics lose their [ __ ]
on me and then the next day be like that
was really uncool and i'm like yeah
thank god i'm in therapy and i'm not
[ __ ] crazy like you too or we would
have been [ __ ] throwing fists it is
the best way to comment goes to you
about hey i was wearing it a lot i'm
sorry and you're like okay great it's
it's over yeah you're like thank you god
you caught that and it's right
you wanted me to smell better
i didn't spill it i had to come and get
my face like a week ago and like
basically say like let's [ __ ] go
let's [ __ ] fight i can't
wait can we
i don't know i think i'm gonna flip it
in her favor i forgot so fast that i
made a rule that i didn't want to say
exactly i was like who was it sam no i
don't want to throw his number
but it was it was literally a week ago
and he was like let's [ __ ] oh he got
my face he's like how [ __ ] let's [ __ ]
go and i was like wow am i gonna have to
fight this like i'm gonna get my ass
kicked this sucks by the way the guy
that does that is the number the guy you
think it's gonna be no you would think
in your head you go lewis gomez
no it wasn't lewis no lewis is actually
laughing really hard
you yeah no no i mean i remember one
time mark and i were at cbs and some
guy's screaming at mark it's mark is
we're all bombing mark is kind of you
remember that it's cb's coming back and
mark can't get [ __ ] cause the crowd's
horrible and one guy keeps heckling him
and lewis gets the guy's face and goes
[ __ ] [ __ ] and the guy's like ah and
louise goes you and me outside right now
and he drags the guy outside in front of
his girlfriend he goes [ __ ] and the
guy's like ah and he goes you [ __ ]
[ __ ] he just humiliates him and i was
kind of like i'm really glad that guy's
on our side you gotta love that you
haven't thank god i'm on your side
that's amazing anyway this guy gets in
my face he's trying to like fight and
i'm just like hey man let's calm down
it's not a big deal anyway it is a big
[ __ ] deal we go outside i have to
wait and i'm like let's talk it out and
after like 20 minutes he goes i was way
out of line you're right that's good
that's rare that's so big you'll be able
to say that i was wrong i'm sorry that's
bad i got off stage this is the work
environment this is another [ __ ] hood
oh exactly it was joe mackey wasn't it
dude i was sitting on my camera once to
film my set i had to make a tape for
somebody and and steve berman's on stage
and i'm only saying this because he
handled it right but like i was steve
byrne yeah steve burns great guy i love
level-headed guy sweet guy yeah and i
was like setting it and i was like all
right let me press record waiting for
him to finish he already has a light and
then he gets off he's like who the [ __ ]
is filming me and he grabs my camera
like it's me on my next on my next i
would never do that to you i wouldn't
i'm not doing anything i'm sitting on my
camera wow and then like i did my set
couldn't tape it and then afterwards hey
man i don't know what i was thinking
all right thank you yeah immediately
ready to be like i thought i'm sorry i
thought it was something that other than
it was yeah well i really regret you
posting this meltdown of yours a second
ago okay
you came off crazy comedians might be a
little uncomfortable
as long as they come to the conclusion
later and you're like hey just watch it
next time give it like give it a minute
before you swing on me next time
yeah
we're friends we're [ __ ] that's the
thing i had to tell this guy was like
you consider me your friend he goes yeah
i was like then don't try to [ __ ]
fight me i know i saw rogue into this
one somebody goes uh hey uh doug
stanhope has the same bid as you i think
he stole it and joe just goes no
oh
well i think he's it goes no
he's like you're not gonna convince me
duck stand up is suddenly a thief
because that's what they want they want
you to get worked up and go yeah because
i don't know the situation you're wrong
oh yeah gross by the way it's like
there's a million [ __ ] we're all
gonna land on the same [ __ ] sometimes
let's not fight i know i got a week
after the chris rocks left yeah they
baited they loved they're like we're
action figures and i had somebody
tweeted like hey hannibal norman's
talking [ __ ] because i got drunk with
hannibal we i told a story about it and
he listened to it and he was like shut
up [ __ ] you and i was like thank god he
listened to dude
yeah the way these dumb dicks that that
do nothing except write to people on the
internet they're trying to start [ __ ]
yeah try to start [ __ ] they don't create
anything they just listen and and try to
start you
yeah they're they're
seems like maybe theft has happened here
it's like it sounds like a conspiracy
theorist trying to connect dots like
it's like i know this is uh
the problem is they never retract they
never attract i had a guy go you stole
this joke from mullany and i'm like i
don't know maybe it's he's got a similar
joke and i looked it up mine was from
2011 his 2015. so i write him that and
he never wrote back yeah how about you
go hey you're not a thief adrian had one
like you stole some bobby bobby lee off
a podcast and she's like well mine was
on the david letterman show which is not
around anymore uh so it was nine years
before this
so you think i stole it so now go accuse
him i heard bobby bobby lead his on tom
snyder
i got it i got it i got into it i am
embarrassed that i even responded but i
got to do it with a guy this morning
because this morning you can't do it you
can't do it i woke up
yeah i woke up and i was just making
coffee and looking at my phone and i see
this tweet and the guy's like
the guy's like you know can somebody
please replace derose on taste buds
what it's your show i know he doesn't
know you guys are gold together thank
you it's a great show
it's thank you perfect
thank you yeah and he's like he's like
he doesn't understand when he's being an
[ __ ] to everybody like whatever but
he listens yeah and i wrote back and i
was just like i just at first there was
a dick and i was just like you don't get
it it's above your head like there's
plenty of low brow entertainment out
there for you whatever and then he's
like you're a [ __ ] hack like that
wow and then i wrote back and i go
listen man
i'm paraphrasing but i go listen i'm
actually going to try to talk to you as
a human being right now that's funny why
do you listen to a show that you hate 50
of it doesn't make any sense i just
don't understand i'm really asking you
why this is self-torture
and i go it would be like watching the
marvel movies just for the thor scenes
if you but you hate the avengers i was
like there are other avenues to get
yourself fixed
a lot of it right
and uh and he was like
you oh joe i'm not talking about your
show simple joe you're so dumb i'm
talking about you you [ __ ] hack
and i go
no dude i'm trying to talk to you like a
human being right now the problem is you
can't i mean the problem is
well exactly these people have too much
access to you where it's like back in
the day you would just hate a guy and
just be like that i don't like that guy
right now it's like hey i don't like you
and we're like oh why don't you we can't
even entertain that so exactly and then
like i have a bit i have a bit about
this and then in my new hour and i i
finally just said to him like i just go
you know what dude i tried to talk to
you like a person i go
you have borderline personality disorder
there's something wrong with you like
you should try to talk about noticing
your followers yeah yo there's something
wrong with you that you feel the need to
be mean like this yeah that yeah you get
enjoyment out of it
this is what it's called you should find
help i i hope you happiness or whatever
and he's like oh simple joe you [ __ ]
hacked it and i go
i'm serious like i hope you find joy in
your life like you're you're there's
something wrong with you yeah and then
he kept doing it and i go look dude he's
not gonna let go he's not gonna like wow
you're just like yeah and you're just
like what in the [ __ ] is wrong like i'm
like i just finally i go i've spent too
much of my time on this dude
i'll see you later like whatever but
it's so not it's that's why this is why
metzger said he like prefers facebook
over twitter because he goes on twitter
you write a joke someone else comes in
and goes um hey you suck whatever it
goes spatially they're equal you write a
tweet he writes a tweet he goes on
facebook you write a tweet and then they
have this itty-bitty little line at the
bottom which is way smaller because
that's where you belong right you're
nothing compared to the [ __ ] artist
who's doing it right that's why i like
sam morel that's true no names but
plenty of times in the back table
samurail and drunk or not we'll go hey i
don't like you
go away
and you're like you're not doing it
online you're doing it man to man i love
that you did i didn't know you did that
i loved it occasionally occasionally
horrible it's got someone's got to be
horrible and folks this is to the booker
no that's awesome that you do that
i never look i never look at the i
really if i look i looked at the simon
rex comments on that episode because
every comment every message i got was
like my i love this episode so like all
right let me look so i looked at those
comments they were so positive i almost
never look at comments well with the
simon
simon did this episode and people killed
him evelyn loved it he seems like he's
really really really really nice
he's a mensch and he's like he's got
amazing stories and he's just he also
listens to this so he just came with
like he was like so prepared that's
awesome he killed it but so much better
than you guys
i rarely i rarely look at comment
comments are not because if they're good
you don't believe them and if they're
bad they make you feel bad no it's bad
so that's the problem is like the good
ones you're like well that's not real
and the bad ones bring you down jay said
it the best because the comments are
people who were fan like stern comments
he goes they're they're for stern
they're they're gonna watch every
episode and they go i hated this episode
they're not hoping stern watches this
they're just talking to each other right
they're fans they're watching every
episode and the people who like it
aren't writing right no one's like i
love this yeah i love this uh this
episode whatever they just they just go
i hate this and then move on they're not
the good guys aren't writing yeah and
also like guess what man it's a free
show you're gonna like some episodes
we're not gonna like others we're doing
our best we want this to be a show that
people that's what yeah that's why i
like the edinboro free fringe because
people like this sucks like just leave
you've paid nothing take off yeah and
yeah and it's the same to a podcast it's
like i've said that to certain fans
where they [ __ ] i go oh i'm sorry that
we're giving you free entertainment
every week go [ __ ] off yeah i wish i
could be like what do you want like too
many ads it's free you [ __ ] twice go
pay five bucks a month for peacock
[ __ ] yeah like [ __ ] off man the
audi oh yeah all you're hearing now
online is you can affect comedians if
you write
if you message me everyone message joe
simple joe right yeah
i was drunk when i wrote that out simple
joe
well we're all obsessed with reaction
that's our whole job as stand-ups here
laughs hear laughs hear a groan see
where we're at see what we do it's all
feedback so comments are uh
if they throw us off i i i agree with
that uh but i would say
my new stance on all this is i'm tired
of
feeling afraid
let's be let's all be honest
nobody none of us
none of us are not reacting to trolls
because we want to be the bigger man
we're all not reacting to trolls because
of a fear of what it will
what it will bite us in the ass with
so you interact well you unlock that
once you unlock that door you're it's
the whole world
mayhem it's right good but my point is
but and that's well that's that's part
of my point
it's part of it is every troll is amber
heard it'll feel good to trash them for
a second but then in the end you're like
i should not but here's the thing it's
not even trashing them it's jus it
doesn't have to be at least right it's
any interaction where i don't agree with
you
the troll mentality is i'm going to go
harder now yeah so eventually it's going
to lead back to fake review bombings or
whatever the [ __ ] it is to hurt you in
any way they can that is where it will
end up and i'm just quite frankly tired
of living in fear of the taste buds
anthrax package you know like yeah i'm
like tired of it i'm tired of being i'm
tired of going well god forbid i speak
my mind about this because that group of
fans then will come after me and do this
to me right or these people will get my
personal information and post it or
these people i have uh
coming out and they'll ruin the reviews
or whatever the [ __ ] it is i'm tired of
living in some marginal fear of what
these [ __ ] animals on the internet
will do
where it suddenly takes away
basic decency and human interaction if
anyone and i'm not being cliche i hope
i'm not at least if somebody says to you
if somebody said any of these things to
you in public
you would never just walk away
you would say hey man
why are you saying that right now like
no no no let's talk you're trying to
reason with you're wrong but because
they're not looking for but there aren't
that many lunatics out there no based on
what you're seeing on the internet do
you see them saying you never would
encounter that many lunatics ever really
have you been on the one train lately
sure well i'll tell you this i am a
troll and i enjoy trolling but at least
you admit to being a troll these people
think they're normal no they know their
trolls but you i disagree they know the
trolls the point is to get a reaction
from you so it doesn't matter what i say
if it's like what are you what are you
weird about your glasses am i feeling
glasses oh that's not that's a
nonstarter your pants sorry that's not
working hey i hate egypt that's not
working your curly hair is dumb until i
get something to [ __ ] get around a
problem with every one of those things
yeah
so it's something out of you i don't
care because you're i'm just trying to
rise up your thing is your thing is is
i'm gonna make outlandish jokes that
piss off people that are being way too
sensitive yeah and you're not gonna make
them at anybody you're just gonna make
them publicly and watch people just
react there's a big difference that's
not what i'm talking about there's a big
difference you're i'm talking about
people that seek you out to say things
personally to you that are in a certain
way personal and we have to play this
whole game of be the bigger man don't
respond if they if you respond they're
getting to you how many times will you
write something back to a troll and
they'll go
bro
all i care about is i got you to respond
[ __ ] you and you're like
you're like no dude like that
i i'm just so sick of it i'm just so
sick of it after all that kobe stuff
that everyone's coming at me like death
threats and [ __ ] and i had fun with it i
was like at some point like well i know
this is happening so i wrote to my
friends i was like hey if you guys got a
stand-up clip the eyes are on my
instagram right now
we can get some eyeballs that's smart
yeah and so michelle gave me one i
probably a couple you guys gave me one
monroe martin was one of the guys who's
like gave me a clip so i put it up and
people are calling them i mean really
dark racist really because it's
defensive kobe in defensive combat yeah
calling him up
like old style [ __ ] amazing and monroe's
like he didn't have a dad so he's his
own dad so he's like hey let's meet up
let's [ __ ] fight if you want to fight
they're like oh i didn't mean it like
that right yeah monroe didn't take it at
all i remember i was right after ari did
that we were leaving the stand i was
like i'll go to the cellar with you i
was like
taxi
i'm not i'm not taking this walk with
all right it was right when i moved back
to new york and i remember walking
around with ari and like because we
lived in the same neighborhood we lit
like two blocks from each other
so i hung out with aria a lot right
after that happened and uh i remember
every time somebody would come up and be
like are you our fear i'd be like oh
[ __ ]
and then they always were like i love
your stuff and it's like
yeah in person i love your stuff for
bird is fat it's never anything bad
there you go oh simple joe i don't have
any problem with sorry but i mean am i
making i don't know if i'm making sense
like i i uh we can't talk to you yeah
yeah yeah i got it you talk to them
because you think they're normal and
then they're not normal it's like oh my
back you got me congrats but you got to
think like the way i'll make a joke
about amber heard or elon musk or or
trump or whatever
they think they're doing that to us this
is my doctorate and i'm like oh what are
you
but you got to remember you're you had a
tv show you're on uh whatever you know
youtube like you got a million views
they think they're just talking to a
celebrity or something so they think
they're talking to a web designer they
don't really think they're actually
talking to you until you respond like oh
[ __ ] well like imagine all the jokes
we've made about biden or johnny
or whatever or will smith the great if
biden really responded like that yeah
what if amber heard wrote back like hey
that's actually really hurtful i'm like
oh
yeah
and they think that they're not gonna
think we're gonna write back yeah but
we're [ __ ] comedian [ __ ] drunks
would any of you roll the dice and sleep
with amber heard yeah sure of course
clearly getting clearly got great i
think we're all in agreement here yeah
yeah i mean do it for the story yeah
it's not even a roll of the dice it will
be the
four years later cut the four years
later oh simple ari you [ __ ] amber
heard and she ruined your life hoping
she does only fans to pay the legal
bills i mean
that would be fun imagine afterwards we
were like what did you think was gonna
happen she wasn't gonna go after you in
court like i don't know she blew me so
well yeah it's tough i mean she's a good
looking lady she's not that hot she's
really really she's hot she's active
yeah she's not like oh my god
which was the worst thing or mordecai
for johnny depp what do you think i
think uh
maybe secret window
yeah she's she's like that was a plans
when he was with her come on yep
she's fine she's got a track record
she's got a quite a list of dudes who
else
uh
elon musk no way she [ __ ] musk oh yeah
for a while i think um dicaprio i'm
looking at uh james franco franco that's
wow
no one understands what actors are
they're just [ __ ] everybody sure elon
musk that after something that toxic he
had to buy twitter
yeah i just stopped people talking [ __ ]
about him right right
oh there they are look at that wow wow
she's a small lady
oh they all all the actresses are tiny i
feel like well uma thurman's i think six
one yeah cruises five he's like rogan oh
yeah i guess nicole kidman also tall
tall tall cup and
australians should we do the rest of the
news stories now or not
oh yeah the ones you sent me were funny
yeah we got i mean why don't we do oh
here's a good one brazil police find
over 3 million dollars worth of nazi
memorabilia and pedophiles home this is
great while the suspect was already
being arrested on child rape charges he
is now facing additional counts of
racial discrimination and illegal
possession of firearms i like how this
was not a story but for just [ __ ]
children and there's like oh is that
nazi memorabilia
oh this is real
also who who does the uh the appraising
of nazi and memorabilia
this isn't just your year the worst
episode of pawn stars ever
yeah it's the auction house going say
it's three million that one
can you imagine how should we suffer uh
your boyfriend is a nazi and it gets
worse yeah
he's a pedophile i mean i feel bad for
kumia but
it's right around here damn not what's
what's brazilian nazi memorabilia went
to south america argentina argentina oh
wait were the boys from brazil was that
that's close enough
argentina is
yeah they played for the argentinian um
jewish league volleyball team yeah they
canceled when i was in israel and it was
like can somebody form an argentino team
and we did and they chanted for us
because we didn't know what we were
doing like argentina
do you guys want to do bits instead
i don't know
[ __ ] off solo queues
all right back to the news this is nice
good stuff scientists just found that
several anti-5g products meant to
protect people from cell networks emit
dangerous radiation
you got to love that you got to love
someone who goes out of their way to
protect themselves something we all do
eats it in the end yes the items which
include necklaces and sleep masks emit
low levels of ion radiation they can
danger be dangerous of worn consistently
and permanently damage the tissue and
the dna ah how about that it's like an
air bag that kills you it's like not
supposed to happen right yeah it's like
it's like it'll stop you from a crash
but it's got asbestos in it
you guys rock sleep mass ever planes
once in a while i love them
they do the job blocks out the light
it's great they feel like you're being
hugged like an autistic person i love it
yeah my dog i used to have a chihuahua
and it was the most annoying dog and you
put a a little thing on its chest it was
called a thunder jacket thunder jacket
you know about it yeah and they would
just get one they love it's a hug it's a
non-stop hug it's a hug instead of
barking
[Music]
exactly 37 jelly beans
i think that might be it for the new no
there was another one mug shot no you
sent me some i had two we went to a few
before you got here all right oh the
right there's a whole new set of news
stories that matt sent us should the
microsoft mate yet yeah well what do you
got on that i mean i love cheating to
get ahead
listen chael sonnen won a fight against
somebody and he he held onto the cage
and the guy was trying to lift him up
and he goes like well you should have
been abducted a point and he said if you
ain't cheating you ain't trying damn
this guy is getting his rapes in
he's getting in no matter what and he
goes i'll say oh i'm a girl i'm a girl
whatever it takes and the swimmer good
luck to you too leah thomas sure you're
winning [ __ ] medals you weren't going
to do that as a [ __ ] dude i don't
know where you compare leah thomas to
this guy that yeah
they're both the top of the game at penn
state it's right there your second best
this woman whatever no one's gonna care
i said guy for that one it's a rapist
matt do you send him the other news
stories yeah south keys you should've
gotten some other news stories oh i
don't did you send a new one there it is
let's see we got
uh florida bride and her
caterer
wow allegedly served cannabis lace food
to unknown guests several of the
unwitting guests became so stoned they
had to be hospitalized
listen um
i'm not against themselves
because that's usually the only way to
get some people there
you gotta go against their will it's
it's fine it's just weed or it's just
molly or something people are
hospitalized no
the the mistake they made which is like
i made a mistake people eat a lot of
weddings ari i made a mistake with bert
i didn't get his wife too
and i made this guy once they started
calling the cops at that point goes guys
guys you're on weed you should have just
told them you're on weed we've all we've
all done it mark and i are now hot heads
so we've taken it we've been like what
the [ __ ] oh dude it feels like it's
never gonna end the edible is a
different ball game it's a it's a six
hour to 12-hour trip i wouldn't need to
be hospitalized but i'd have to go home
and rethink some things yeah
but kim cogden got me at skank fest i
saw that what yeah and and i i mean it's
not like i haven't done that before i'm
on a [ __ ] dork but like i was [ __ ]
up on asset and i opened up my hotel
room they put me in and it was a [ __ ]
view of downtown houston and i opened up
the windows floor to ceiling i got all
my bed spreads brought it over to the
window wow i just chilled for like five
hours just staring at the city damn it
was great but i couldn't hang out with
everybody negative positive it was a
[ __ ] great vibe you made the most of
it thank you there you go
see you've been dosed and you've dosed
it's true what's good for the goose is
good for the anal all right all right uh
a man allegedly threatened to bomb the
merriam-webster offices over the
dictionary definitions of girl and woman
you know what's good about this story it
could either be a conservative or a
liberal it could go either way you're
right you're right that's true well
you're like is this a dude who was like
a woman is born a woman or it could be a
guy who's like how dare you say it's a
woman how dare you try to define what a
woman is without it really is just it
signifies who we are now it's not just
like i'm against it but like i'll
threaten to bomb you over i don't agree
with you over words well which one is it
can we figure that out what is it uh is
it a blue haired lady or is it a guy in
a golfer that
says batman movie's gonna have a really
shitty villain if joker is like you guys
need to why'd i bomb the hospital
because you guys aren't up to date on
gender identity okay this is cucks right
right oh here's what i said remember
this female include
of relating to or being the sex that
typically has the capacity to bear young
or produce eggs
and having gender identity that is the
opposite of male again could go either
way at this point now that could be
right obvious which one is it i think
it's a it's a psycho uh lefty here hmm
what could it be the other way it's
california it could be either it's got
true yeah couldn't it be like no it's
not typically having a gender identity
that is the opposite of male it's a
chick i'm guessing i'm guessing psycho
lefty but i didn't read them
what i mean
one photo and we would figure it out
yeah hey peters do we know who
all right it's gonna be a lady who looks
like matt peters that's my guess yeah
which you don't want to see oh
simple joe good to have you back
are we going to call this episode this
simple joke temple joe bourbons
there you go we got to do a patreon
stuff oh that's right three in a day
it's it's a full-time anal oh my god god
damn it you got a photo sale oh yeah no
let's just do this last story it's too
good oh this is so good i read this
earlier take it jojo match the crime to
the midge oh mug shot black dj accused
of wearing blackface as the arizona pta
event by woke education leaders says he
was horrified to learn of their
complaints and initially thought it was
a joke
so he did like a 70s throwback dj thing
and he wore a wig and they accused him
of putting on black face turns out he's
a black guy how can you do a black face
if you're not even talking about the
face
gotta make sure joe is a mic too oh joe
needs to mic yeah switch back why oh
that's the point they thought he was
being racist and where like a white
house so they thought his actual skin
color because of the wig was makeup
interesting so if you're black you can
do black though do you see this is how
headlines read by the way now like
rambling children
dj accused of black face wearing black
face by a woke person at an event
because they got confused by it's like
what the [ __ ] happened to like succinct
yeah instead of like hey turns out a
bunch of losers were wrong
yeah that's the story hey luke is wrong
again after the woman was corrected and
saying no this is a black guy let me
guess what she didn't do go oh [ __ ] i'm
an idiot no he said still it's wrong
what let me guess white woman
dude all my amazing racist stuff when i
told people like this is [ __ ] wrong
what happens to mexicans or whatever
it's like they have to go out of their
way to work i'm like oh those are
actually all paid actors we gave them 50
bucks each we're actually giving money
to the latino community it's a setup and
they go still
wait still you thought i was delivering
mexicans to ins and instead you think
i'm doing a sketch and you're equally
angry
not even like well a little less i guess
you know you know who's jealous black
people get to do blackface is uh justin
trudeau
yeah yeah he saw this he like that looks
pretty good
black face with no repercussions
must be nice that's her and that's the
blackface guy and that's the complaint
and she
like her reaction quote yeah i'll look
for it sorry it's crazy white people are
getting mad at black people for
blackface now it's bad the arrogance of
this they used to be called racism white
is incredible the arrogance
instead of go [ __ ] i was ray walking up
the wrong tree on this one
damn i accused a black guy of putting on
black makeup turns out i thought black
skin was the same as black makeup i'm an
idiot no that can't be it's just it's
unreal
it's un
[ __ ] real that's bad it's it's it's
we've
gone to a
backwards land we should wrap up cause
we gotta do a patreon yeah yeah wait is
wrap up like we should we should end
this oh i think about we all do a rap
we'll do yeah we're all making rounds
look at this let me be clear a black man
apparently in blackface is an entirely
different discussion than a white person
however i did not state that the person
was white
[Music]
it was assumed that my intent and
perhaps it was but nonetheless looking
on his facebook page
it seems at the very least he is in
darker makeup if not that face he's not
in any darker makeup down he you saying
he put on darker no lady
yeah god damn we got too much time on
our hands we gotta send this lady to a
like a like a boot camp or a you know
sweatshop she looks like a [ __ ]
who goes after [ __ ] white dudes all
the time yeah
easy there big fella
i'm not gonna do what it is
all right all right let's plug somebody
some stuff yeah
what are you doing tank chase comes out
in a year and a half taste buds on
youtube uh and then uh
of course uh
our taping
may
19th and 22nd in houston texas at the
come and take it festival being held at
the secret group in houston texas uh one
show thursday one show sunday and then
in between those shows on friday and
saturday that the 20th and 21st i'll be
at uh the creek and cave in austin texas
all right and taste buds is great uh
mine is great thank you yeah one of the
worst guests i was i love the show i
can't stand simple joe in that [ __ ] yeah
it's so simple
really every clip is gold it's it's a
great channel that's great you got the
tank ari saphir love it you're sweet
what i think i got a lot of air time
that troll yours you gave them a lot of
air time that's what they want
all right
i gotta get a new website look how much
better yours looks i just redid mine
what are you kidding this looks like a
nightclub
uh
this is squarespace yeah mind
squarespace what am i doing wrong uh you
have lots of lack of education
look at mine
what the [ __ ] is that html of angelfire
i gotta redo my squarespace site what
the hell is this
oh wait i already gotta slow down you're
gonna be in jacksonville on may 12th
through the 14th
yeah i got one right here oh okay
may 28th 21st in kansas city in austin
in may 24th through the 29th
at my special day
12th we'll be out in the summer
youtube
uh we'll see i just shoot him first and
then we figure that out
netflix is through the floor so we'll
see what happens maybe i can buy them
yeah
all right all right website
i'll be yeah that's a beauty yeah yeah
george website
you gotta make that bigger looks as good
as your [ __ ] yeah
you're doing denver for one night only
you're not doing the [ __ ] i'm at the
paramount one night only the irvine
improv
uh keep going keep going addison improv
in dallas bricktown and okc one of the
best clubs what are the best new clubs
great love room love it uh laughing up
in poughkeepsie one night only keeps
going keep it going
uh
stand up live
june first first weekend you were just
there i was just there chicago at the
vic cleveland
minnesota the night before me june 16th
yes minneapolis come on out chicago the
vic the night before me june 17th irvine
you got to go faster come on there we go
red bank new jersey houston improv
all right laugh out loud in san antonio
sammy the bull what are you doing
uh providence i got chicago taping a
special at the den six shows we're
taping all of them so beautiful beacon
is sold out when is a beacon uh beacon
we passed that [ __ ] dude that was
congratulations you already did it no
but we're this is we've we're back
in the studio this is a beautiful
website toronto thank you i didn't do it
i had nothing to do with it toronto
uh [ __ ] houston west palm san jose
all that [ __ ] y'all see you around dania
beach
yeah yeah fun room fun
dot com flash frames we might be drunk
dot com from words patreon.com we might
be drunk
two special guests today yes and we had
salamanca hell yeah yeah
looking good thanks boys
love you let's suck dicks
[Music]
sunday's close
i've had a little too
[Music]
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
way
we might
be
true
[Music]